dans les rues de kharkiv par tous les
stigmates de la guerre alors que les
combats s'intensifient dans la deuxième
ville d'ukraine pour ceux restés sur
place le quotidien est fait de
débrouille ici les habitants recueil de
l'eau de pluie et d'ingéniosité pour
pallier les difficultés
pas vraiment cuisiner ici parce que le
bois va bientôt valoir de l'or c'est
difficile de s'en procurer si un garage
est touchée on va chercher des palettes
en bois où peut-on trouver autrement si
un arbre est touchée on va l'extraire et
le coupé
nous n'avons pas d'électricité pas d'eau
pas de communication du tout et pas de
gaz dans le quartier de salt ifca les
habitants réfugiés dans le sous sol de
cette école compte aménager l'espace
avec les moyens du bord
voici l'endroit où nous d'armes au cfai
de table du bureau école et deux chaises
nous avons utilisé ce que nous avions
nous avons pris des tapis de couchage à
l'école dans cette organisation de
fortune les habitants peuvent compter
sur la solidarité d'associations locales
ou
encore des bénévoles nous apportent du
chou lors des betteraves des haricots en
conserve et des garnitures on mélange
tout et on en fait une source
depuis le début de la semaine et
l'offensive russe dans l'est de
l'ukraine la russie affirme avoir débuté
une nouvelle phase dans la guerre